l' académie des dalons est un projet
expérimental d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle qui s'adresse à des
volontaires motivés âgés de 18 à 25 ans
un dispositif mis en place par le
conseil départemental qui a pour
objectif de redonner confiance aux
jeunes dans leurs capacités en
favorisant le développement personnel et
citoyens la septième promotion a fait
son arrivée il ya quelques semaines
durant trois mois ils seront en internat
au bernica ces promotions là est arrivé
depuis jeudi dernier et déjà demain et
après-demain ils partent sur un raid de
dépassement sur cilaos simon faire de la
marche de l'escaladent et du canyon et
ils vont une mine inondée situation à la
fois de découvertes et des situations de
dépassement pour là c'est un peu ça le
coeur du métier de l'académie des talons
c'était personnes retrouvent de
l'énergie du dynamisme et aussi puissent
construire tranquillement
des projets qui leur correspondent à
partir de leurs ressources qu'ils ont
ils ont identifié tout au long de ce
contre un engagement qui est de 12 mois
donc il ya une période de trois mois en
internat et ensuite les personnes
passent sur des missions de service
civique sur la deuxième partie les
jeunes volontaires bénéficient d'un
encadrement individualisé des activités
variées et adaptées au rythme et aux
besoins de chacun sont mises en place
par des professionnels qualifiés un
accompagnement permanent fait d'écouté
de conseils pour permettre aux
volontaires de se responsabiliser et de
devenir autonome donc c'est concourir à
peu à elle a fait une finalité
d'insertion donc par le sport ça va
passer par un travail autour du
développement personnel de la personne
un bien-être physique un bien-être
psychologique
on va travailler autour aussi de la
posture posture citoyenne autour du
respect des règles par exemple avec un
arbitrage avec avec un cadre précis ray
que des réactions contrôle émotionnel
sur le terrain par exemple concourir un
petit peu de manière générale à une
santé santé physique et mentale et
travail et beaucoup autour du
dépassement de soi du voile est fort de
l'engagement des jeunes pour la plupart
en difficulté sociale étaient scolarisés
désireux d'améliorer leurs connaissances
et leurs compétences
il voit en l'académie des dalons une
véritable seconde chance et vise ainsi
l'intégration dans une formation
professionnelle c'est pour moi pour la
cabine mais pour nous tous c'est quand
même quelque chose de bien parce que son
père est dû
développer notre sens notre savoir faire
mais aussi la motivation qu'on à dire
tout ça est
pour moi ça porte à certains comme ça
certains m'ont certaine mentalité mois
voilà c'était mortalité est responsable
des actes plus mature aussi voilà
maintenant ma vie d'aujourd'hui n'est
pas facile beaucoup de jeunes sont
exclus et difficilement l'ont pas c'est
pas facile aussi pas évident tous les
jours donc c'est une grande chance pour
moi et pour tous les jeunes de
l'académie de tissus internes pendant
trois mois l'hébergement des transports
la restauration les cours les activités
les tenues de travail et fournitures
sont prises en charge par le département